sotto attivo in tornati su wired torres
allora se non sempre abbiamo uno studio
e come potete vedere ancora arretrato
background però mi raccomando atti
materia notizie in una compagna ina
perché in questi giorni sto decidendo
come arredarlo sto leggendo sui consigli
nei commenti a cui mi sono piaciuti
tantissimo e in questi giorni farò
appunto di blog mentre l'arredo lo
studio il palco secondo passo un po
vedere me sicuramente che ha frenato
ancora e poi faccio un background
assieme a voi quindi milan formativa
televisivi che prevede i blog e lasciate
un bel live se volete catering in
anteprima se volete vedere più browser
di curiosità nascose alle belloni che
allora oggi andiamo a vedere a grande
richiesta per questo video vi è piaciuto
tantissimo il live sax trucchetti più
stupidi estranei e furbi che io non
capisco la gente che riguarda non lo so
se rican fisse ne ho trovato altri non
mi occorrono più questo punto la tabella
le copertine queste stefano quel piccolo
pc quindi andiamo a vedere le sere come
sempre lasciato un bel live mettetevi
comodi o cosa fa dire cosa che dovrai
cristo che di volta mi di spendere
troppo e vediamo un po che si levano
come sembrava finito il video leggeremo
quale è stato il più assurdo o il più
stupido
quindi se niente neppure e diamo un voto
per utilità a tutti anche voi potrete
andare in moto nei commenti
ci siamo subito allora il trucchetto il
numero 1 vediamo con tappa a questo
smartphone amore sta morendo
no non l'abbiamo lamelle flash from sono
scorso per quindi forse non lo rovino
permanentemente dal colorato di blu a
questo questo l'ho visto e di rosso e
dovrebbe fare una luce speciale cioè la
luce viola per vedere il ces sporco
numero uno gli dopo utilità
sì perché per altre cose può essere
usato qualche il malocchio moschea
numero 1 vediamo il prossimo
allora camion e di emergenza accenti un
pennarello indelebile e non funziona più
ha dovuto continua a funzionare allora
che voto date a questo numero 2 quand'è
che avete bisogno di una cartella di
emergenza meramente quando c'è bisogno
di cambiare del progetto io vi do un 5
voi che voto gli date questo rende molto
carino l'ho provato anch'io questo
trucchetto in cui fai diventare le
finanziatore arcobaleno
sidin un bel botto perché questo è bello
e tu che una candela c'è sempre qualche
candela dimensioni smartphone e campbell
sta scegliendo un spazzolino
[Musica]
perché questo giochetto numero 4 di docu
2 voi foto di latte di temi nei commenti
vediamo zucchetto numero 5 questo l'ho
provato nei circuiti non gli posso dare
molto basse ma no che comunque questo è
passi i muscoli con i rotoli di carta
igienica
ma malamente vedere il risultato ma come
oddio messo carta elezione e borotalco
che cosa dire ha fatto il fondotinta
pato in casa col caffè narrazione del
moro talco ok in bocconi sono vestiti
bene però quindi questo trucchetto mondo
non 5 di don 6 trucchetto numero 6
vediamo cosa ha fatto in questa si
limita
come ha fatto entrare così facilmente
lamela
ok questo se funziona e figo gli darei
un otto prendendo dei pezzi di tutto con
la screen per farebbe numero 7 in un
noto lo stesso carino mettere un tappo
di bottiglia vediamo quando arrivano in
fila i fan scritto pd anche se pensiero
non è male sempre mezzo numero 8 sta
infilando una cannuccia nella banana
[Musica]
questa interessante interessante la
manina ritiene minutella adesso lo ha
provato da te mi sembrano i commenti se
volete che non provi poi sta usando nel
file per natale un po pubblicato questi
non fare per gli amici
per me per tagliare i booster ma non fai
prima a tagliare con il coltello
questo di fare laimer con la copertina
per capelli ormai perso il conto sentito
numero 10 vorrei provarlo in poter
risolvere nei commenti e forse che provi
altri trucchetti strani di bellezza
contattato altri vini al riguardo mi son
piaciuti tanto quindi fatemi sapere se
volete credere che trucchetto numero 11
pensavo perso il conto come sempre santa
caterina l'ombrello per lì non ti arriva
la pioggia né il vetro non era basato
tra sparta secondo me se cammini con
quello dove tv da un noto per la
divertente questo canale si chiama chi
che i cartai appicca a a y se potete
guardarvelo sembrava molto simpatico per
un trucchetto numero 16 questo video era
in training e volevo appositamente
guardarlo con voi perché town l
scandalosa quindi vediamo un po se
funziona acqua sono state semplicemente
in tempo per il matitone una carezza la
matita è troppo corta balenario un sette
e mezzo perché può funzionare numero 17
unendo due consigli per creare quei
fazzoletti
tipo un porta graffette ok
studiamo insieme questo numero di
sospettavamo numero 18
prendi una molletta attacca alla pistola
l'acqua calda per farlo stare in piedi
ok abbiamo giunte e mezzo perché
funziona almeno dai numero 18
stamattina il temperino dentro il coso
del momento king air la ritaglia un po
mare lo metto però anche questo funziona
dai quindi illudiamo 7 a questo 18
hannover questo mio giardino
una fiaba ma perché perché dovresti le
gare più appena reale così 19 li diamo
un sei e mezzo albert lo capisco
l'utilità la numero 20 enne un po di
colla ha causato con un accendino per
scioglierla invece fissare la pistola
non capisco perché
per tifare qualsiasi per scomodo
comunque numero 20 è giusto perché
funzionano
stai prendendo dalla un tubetto di colla
finito non ricca ne hanno fatto un buco
al centro stile ma perché 21 questo è
stato inutile perché lì non 4 numero 22
è un copri forbici sma perché per il
caso di farlo ci metta un po anche
questo numero 23 diciamo per arrivare a
quello più epico di tutti allora
avessero d'accordo uno stand e sta
ricucendo di spago che così come
decorazione non era questo 23 fino 15
perché non era l'auto berna canale
numero 24 in a ha fatto la trottola ok
reti e gli fa molte numero 25 i
fiammiferi un po sbucciando i fiammiferi
parlando di nero cosa voglia fare cosa
come capito quello specifico eni con
vendite l'avete capito numero 26 27 27
forse a porta al telefono con una gomma
e bellissimo di secondi si numero 29 se
stiamo avvicinando a quello più etico di
tutti pre notizie spiller attaccato con
i cerchietti e sta mettendo dei pezzi di
cannuccia o per fare le luci diverse uno
smartphone beh queste carino
non male questo lido ragazzi ci siamo
siamo quello più epico di tutti i corsi
siamo al numero 29 o 30 comunque
percorrendo rivederlo questo è un po di
paura di vederlo non so cosa andrà a
fare siete pronti vedevo
[Musica]
ok cosa vuol fare questo chiodo hans
della colla
l'asta carubia è stata l'altra forza a
lui sa ma quindi un accesso alla tav
sveglie che si con il trucchetto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non si può credere
a questo scherzo di carnevale
lo sto e film per questo bene a vista
per i phone e il trucchetto che vi ho
giocato di più quello che ho detto fatto
più strano
sicuramente questo è di più particolare
però quelli che mi hanno fatto più
ridere sono quelli di questi teli prima
su però è quello con gli occhiali in cui
file boccone di occhiali e poi mettere
sempre state ebook quella permessa tempi
di vernet e fatemi sapere se quando vuoi
quale fatto il più divertente
il nostro è un bel vedere altri
struccati stupidi e che fanno ridere e
ora vi lascio papato capelli e potete
scegliere i prossimi mesi a da vedere
anno in posti più divertenti eppure
quella che preferite e buona visione
ma